let's talk about spoiler corner first
bow trap went bad
Chinese dumpling likes just what I like
I look to you in debt Noble yeah that
was the look on your face and I was just
staring at the screen and I'm just like
well I think my exact words were just
why why and we're like it but we can't
we're like it Pixar that those shorts
are usually legs and then and then the
it starts running off and living its
life and I'm like what the hell well
then you make the joke you said would it
be funny if this was all in one day and
I think I was joking the whole time then
at any second she's just gonna be like
oh and then one day then when they
fucking did it
I just sat there and I that's the moment
where I thought if I only happen XS lost
its mind they just they just snapped and
they're like how do I get kids oh my god
two rows ahead of us it doesn't know
we're just here oh my god and there was
like this guess and then silences were
just like well there can't be it there
there must be and they cut to the woman
crying I thought this is this is just
crazy it's just like it isn't finally
they're just like screw you brats we're
gonna make you grab just like so but but
then it's revealed that it she's
projecting that it's her son and the son
comes home and they they make amends and
what's so funny is afterwards your wife
leaned over and said you know I'd
actually okay if it just ended with her
eating the
I know that would have taken real
cojones yeah I mean my life isn't dark
so I'm like okay so that would just be
like growing up your kids from like 5 to
20 like in a millisecond
I just joke I think most adults are you
like I don't want to see that I just
remember turning I was like wow Pixar's
version of Princess Kaguya is really
that dark that's kind of what I was
thinking what did you think of that
short well afterwards I was just like
brought to you by Sigmund Freud like
yeah I think I liked it I think I did
too
I what I just you know I just really
wanted to like I wanted to eat the
dumpling 1 because they're amazing and
looking wishes and because of this
little shit dumplings like yeah I know
but I'm just like I would have eaten it
this is just like was it yeah and then
stumbles off I'm like you little piece
of crap yeah I I mean I I liked it was
it it moves so quick and it was so
jarring that it really did kind of just
throw everybody off and then when you
saw what they're doing it's like here
here's the gimmick and it is emotional
and it does technically work my it's one
of those things where it's like ok but
Shh you know what it's like that with
dumplings ya know that but that that her
eating was so jarring yeah that I think
it really took about it might get us
back like like it wit it worked well
enough and is you know there was shot
like the audience we saw but there was
shock and awe yeah I think they really
yeah I don't think they really got over
it I didn't get over it yeah because and
that's so funny because the moral of the
story is still I'm just like well the
like here's your happy ending kids it's
like the dumpling never existed in the
first place there's a Majan Asian I'm
like yes
this is the links awakening or that
Zelda 3 knockoff game on the Game Boy
it's ya know but it's you know what I'm
kid that you know how you were talking
about you're saying years later you have
to look back at for me that's the short
oh this to see years laters later I may
look waves like this is Brian I might
just be like wow this is just as messed
up and it's very rare I say this I get a
feeling years later I'll like it more
because that was just such a jarring
holy shit moment that definitely left an
impact that whatever it's too much of an
impact but maybe years later it is what
do they do at the end they eat bready
pastries pastry anything again I just be
looking at girl like oh god huh
so that was interesting that was very
very interesting I can't wait to see
other kids because we had we saw this
movie really early there's like a five
o'clock screening which is like I never
even heard of they're usually at 7:00
but so there's only a few people in the
theater it because a lot of people still
get off work and everything and whatnot
I mean there are definitely reactions
but not a ton of kids uh I just can't
wait to hear kids reaction I mean she's
crying afterwards okay a parent I don't
get it how's a kid gonna interpret that
cuz according to them the dumplings dad
kids are weird kids are resilient they
might find it funny I think it's the
adult super more horrified because like
that was a whole metaphor about like
destroying your children I just had wolf
yeah let him go or cut sue me I feel I
feel like this but I felt like cuz I
didn't see this as a kid but I felt like
it bothers me more as a grown-ass adult
to see that that it probably ever would
as a child as a child I think it would
go just right over my it disturbs it on
a different level I think yeah keeps
probably thing like the dumpling turned
into a human or something like that
that'd be my guess but so it's I feel
like I'll grow into it but yeah
very very high just right afterwards
like I just wanted to say like I know I
just want a title card just be like the
end be Incredibles there's something
like this is all one big joke like you
know what part of it is though those
shorts are always so good and there's
they're very well done but they are
comfort food they'll always make you
feel a little bad but oh well I'm
feeling warm it'll know that I felt like
such oh yeah it's just such a punch now
I gotta give them credit for going out
of their comfort zone no make that lead
you want the warm and fuzzy things like
give give me the the Looney Tunes
cartoon with the the dog who thinks the
cat has been baked yeah you know and
then at the end yeah I feed the kitty
and like it's that made me feel all warm
and fuzzy inside the end I didn't feel
warm and fuzzy inside the end I was cuz
then I'm just like wow what an awful
like if she's been having that dream and
this is representing what's been going
on in her life like so she's like this
could have been years of them being
estranged and miserable because the Fiat
maybe yeah maybe the fight did they have
it just got it was a real interpersonal
dynamic time just like this just was
uncomfortable like I'm just like wow
what sort of fight - may have like this
depressing still even after the happy
ending I still was kind of depressed
like you know maybe that's in me because
I was like well it's sad that it came to
bat that she had to have a dream about
eating her own children and then he
comes back he's like alright let's you
know what if it does make a play if it
had more time which I understand why
they couldn't it's a short if they have
more time at the end I feel like I'm
connecting but inside it's like it was
so rude yeah to work that as quickly as
you do out of the bag I'm not saying I
hated it well I kind of liked that
brutality but it's definitely gonna have
that reaction but I felt like that
wasn't I felt like the intention was to
make us feel warm and fuzzy at the end I
was like I don't think that's what yeah
we were still getting over I kind of
respect any more for being brutal yeah
anyway so that was that horrific yeah
detour after we were told by you know we
know
your patients and you and you've been
waiting in there so here's God a movie
and then they show us this short where
they rip our hearts out so here's Olaf's
grand adventure so okay so the big thing
is that again minute you see this damn
woman it's like villain you know this is
the eyes are half open hmm how she's
easing up with a lever like right right
well betray I'll give him I'll give him
this much it took me five minutes maybe
just cuz at first it was like he's the
villain and I'm like oh no wait they're
making him wait to obviously look like
the villain cos he's super nice she's
the villain like it just was well the
fact that you Bob Bodecker play him I
mean he is essentially just playing
himself I mean it's plates all it took
all of five minutes we were like villain
and then the the most insulting thing
because yeah is when she literally looks
at elastico and says you're good I'm
like really because we figured it out
yeah like I hate that like when they
throw a line in like that cuz you're
just like well if we were all nine steps
ahead why wasn't she well in here's
nothing yeah you're right that the crime
fighter's Asia and it's I guess I
shouldn't be too harsh because it's like
it's still technically on kids film a
family film and stuff like that but I'm
I'm with you it's like how long have
they been doing this I mean they've been
out the game for a while but they're
clearly back in it and you know the one
thing that a lot of these movies do
sometimes it works but now this is kind
of turning into a trope is to make it
look like it's not them they'll have
somebody else pretending to be the
person like you know she hypnotizes
another guy his pizza delivery boy red
herring because it's like oh it shows
him watching but I'm like she can
hypnotize me that's one of the things
were they my already told you how she
did it that's being turned into kind of
an obvious trope now where they have
another person to try and trick you but
that's being done so many times in other
movies you know
oh my boon hero he just delivers pizzas
like I'm just like put it together
Elastigirl come on yeah and then what
she does it's like this big reveal
well thank if they come in here I'm
saying oh my god you're good yeah we
talked but there was something I mean
it's not much it's just he's corny
little glasses but there's a fee it was
creeping the kids out that's when the
kids started yeah I'm just like there
was something about that when when he
throws away
yeah but basically when went violent and
it was a jack is he the second all of us
- - yeah it's when - opens the door and
all of them with the glasses on her
staring down at him I'm like man if I
were an eight-year-old or if I were like
a five-year-old watching this movie I
would have just been like out at the
time there was something really creepy
about that I'm like man this is like a
worst nightmare but again one of the
reasons that works you feel that kids
age you feel all their ages I mean he
looks way afraid you know he's terrified
kid voice coming out it's like yeah no I
like the way they and I mean I'm just
like that that was what I'm like yeah
now it's home alone for reals boy yeah
well anyway they talk to each other they
feel exactly their age so when there is
oh hey you know I like I like that to a
point
it's where it's legit creepy I'm just
like yeah I were a little kid watching
this movie that's seen what scared I
help them to a point where it's like
there's a scene where it's like you know
what a violence finding one of the
villains and stuff like that and
civilians hurt girl you bitch ya know
things where it's like oh yeah it's a
it's a damn superheroes movie that's
what it's like she can take a few
punches but yeah I was just like wow
like something kind of weird when you
see like a last a girl with like a hard
drink like a Manhattan berry something
like this this is kind of odd it's like
I've seen drinking in our movies I've
seen Dumbo get fucking drunk but there
is something really weird about just
seeing like the main gear that just got
swirling
come on mommy doesn't get drunk she just
has fun so yeah and I think when it's
kind of what led to the third act it's
still good but it's stopping a ship it's
not there fighting her III me Elastigirl
goes up there to find her and she's a
little menacing there I like what she's
like oh you're getting lightheaded oh
yeah oh it's fun to die now it's like
that was my max my only problem is just
that the villain it was very obvious in
the Moto okay so now let's talk about
the motivation zero sense zero it is
like the most batshit crazy mode like
it's Lear like well my brother wanted to
bring superheroes back so I helped him
this whole time
with the intent purpose of finally
destroying you all once and for all by
making the world hate super I'm like
super super heroes were already illegal
so you're fine
and they were already hauling their
asses up to you could have just told you
my brother
yeah get lost I'm not doing this like
come here they're arrested in the
beginning they're gonna go and she and
the brother bail them out I'm just like
if you're gonna kill what if you're
gonna kill all these people anyway just
tell you from yeah she doesn't really
seem to gimmick raises like he's a child
all right why did you just like stop him
for it I don't know it is a long
complicated conversation between like
her and Elastigirl and stuff like that
that was yes trying to justify toy but
it just feels like you're trying are you
talk about where she's all frozen like
are you talking about early oh I'll talk
about earlier yeah we're trying to
justify when I leave the lights are
flashing over her forehead villain like
yeah yeah I hate it like I felt like in
the third act I mean just would it be
cool it's like it's a sequel is the
incredible sequel and it's like in the
first film yes and drums taking out a
pretty quick but it's you're either
you're fighting these henchmen for a
good chunk of time and then you're
fighting this giant monster if this
giant robotic monster who crannies a
machine but it's like it's film menacing
and there's nothing menacing to go up
against in this third third act I think
that's what bothered me I think I wanted
the ante up the madness and you didn't
really get it yeah menaces they're gonna
crash yeah but that's not
I want that really up that's not as
menacing as the machine in the first day
I like something else there her
motivations not that great and yeah it's
one of those things where it's like a
syndrome surprisingly was a fun villain
oh yeah I love that's just the stupidest
reason to be a villain but they
surprisingly made it work and he was
funny and he was also intimidating while
also kind of like he weren't really on
so many levels and this one is that
they're trying to make more serious and
surprisingly it made it almost more
funny like cuz the superheroes didn't
save my dad and he believed weirdly cuz
it's like okay we had to justify why no
no I was laughing when I first saw that
scene it was like ah guess he didn't
believe in a panic room and then later
Israel's we had a panic room he didn't
want to go to them like oh my god this
just felt really complicated it's just
dumb who doesn't go to a panic room even
if you got why don't you put the fucking
phones in the panic room yeah you don't
believe in super girls like it just was
bet it was like strangely bad writing
I wasn't every problem I have in this
movie is centered around her the more I
think about it centered around that
character yeah and like I said it's not
it's not God like it doesn't distract
too much but it's like man this one it's
just it's miss topics we need a better
hit if one it's a it's a very missed
opportunity because for most of the film
you know the kids come in just kind of
save the day at the end which I thought
was super cool when they had yeah when
they came in to save the day like and
we're driving the car and everything I'm
like and once again I think of it like
if I were a kid I would've loved this
yeah use like my kids are yes
it doesn't play yeah it really feels
like um it worked up too but for the
most part it's a missed opportunity with
the voom because for the most part it's
Elastigirl versus this other woman I'm
like you've got to females kind of
duking it out and I'm like well this is
cool this should be really and it just
the village is flying up she has no
superpowers you know what I'm saying
it's like there should if there's a
motivation there it would have been
interesting but I'm like you blew an
opportunity to have like a female
supervillain fight a female like villain
or I mean a female superhero fight a
female villain like and make it really
interesting and it just it really wasn't
cuz the motivation is or you have to
give her something cool if she can do
you know she had like a robot or a
machine or some sort of cool suit or
something like that but she just flies
the jet up and makes her lose oxygen you
know and it's like that's just there
wasn't even like I feel like for a tech
expert yeah it just came down to like
I'm gonna shut the oxygen off like yeah
I mean you're right
like they could have blown that you
Talia was going off she was wearing a
mask
yeah but I mean that it just I don't
know I felt like that was a missed
opportunity it's like if you ask me what
the weakest thing in this film is is
definitely the villain I the only weak
thing honestly because everyone else I
thought just direct bullseye yeah no I
can't god ed the return of Edna yeah if
you're yeah if you to just tell me it's
like an end I get to design a baby suit
it's like a who cares but it's but then
when they did it I'm just like oh my god
the laughs and then and then the raccoon
and then the spit-take yeah the nose yes
that was the scene where it's like she's
drinking the water and just the the oh
look it's only for a split second but
the look on her face that she shoots is
it really like I had to really control
myself and I had to just think of
something else cuz just thinking about
it was cracking me it's yeah it's man
where there's some funny scenes in this
movie like I don't know I feel like
between this and Deadpool to like like I
see a lot of good comedy
there's a lot of comedies out there but
it's like so rare that I see something
so funny I have to like control myself
they both to keep the laughter undercook
how in our review for Deadpool 2 we were
joking about how like well they'd never
make a Deadpool movie where he has to
take care of a baby but watching this
movie I'm like you could totally do it
and I think it would be dark is fucking
hilarious yeah because like looking at
this movie I'm just like oh you totally
could have had Deadpool taking care of
his I'm like you may have to fling that
baby the father yeah I would pay a
thousand bucks is it just cuz like can
you imagine like shootouts with the baby
involved and like yeah but let's find
everywhere yeah I'm trying to think
there's anything else no I just think
yeah just story wise just as a basic
story I think that was one of my
problems was it's just like I I thought
that was the whole point of the first
one we're gonna make heroes kind of
legal again like oh your reputations are
gonna and instead think ghostbusters to
it or it's just like no I still hate
someone no it's it's so weird
that's what I thought I was gonna move
good I never thought I saw the monsters
- I said I thought I was going to I feel
like the characters are strong enough
that the whole thing works but on a
simple story level I feel we've kind of
gone nowhere when it comes to kind of
like the environments because like wow
we still just okay like still gonna make
villains like that I I'm like almost
gonna be like are they gonna do a third
one now or it's like yeah we're still
not fully loved guess we got it like you
know what's funny is that the end
credits the I've seen the end credits
with The Incredibles a lot because
they're some of the best end credits
ever and then uh and they recreate like
the first maybe 20 seconds exactly the
same like it's the exact same shots
exact same punches that cuts the same
people you know written and directed by
Brad first we can literally use the
exact same credits at first and then it
goes into different stuff uh and I'm
thinking to myself you know this you
really should make this a series you
should make this an ongoing series I
think they should grow up definitely and
I think
I think this was fine and this could she
come up faster cuz at the end of this I
swear to god it was almost gonna say The
Incredibles will return in 2036 and III
want another one
I mean films are so good it's like they
really do leave you wanting more and I I
don't want to be my mother but God would
viewer thank you for your patience
[Laughter]
so yeah that's I can't think of anything
else just creepy ass opening short and
weak Vil isn't so yeah like I said got
what you've already seen if you're
watching this so yeah come on it love it
absolutely loved it I can't wait for a
third one get a third one going to just
start out I can't wait for years
you